all right um
okay so um as rachel you know started
the introduction um today we're here to
talk about
um
a little bit of the project workflow for
exploring tree data projects um and i
actually gave this
talk originally last month with our
ladies bergen um and and that was my
actual first early uh first talk i guess
um i should say
um
so i'm
sort of repeating but with a little bit
of uh addition from since then and now i
found out two more packages so i've
added as in in my last slide i'm not
talking about it too much uh because i
didn't have enough time to um you know
explore it so much but i guess they look
promising and so i added the links so
you know if you come back to these um
come back to this um
um
[Music]
deck later uh which i'll be sharing with
rachel and uh i think in the meetup
group um you would have you'll have
access to those links
um so all right let's get it going um
so i guess to begin with about myself um
i'm a data science practitioner and i
also do some side uh gigs on freelancing
um at this point i currently work as a
data science consultant with um on point
insights and i uh you know sort of
consult a client in biomedical devices
company uh leading their um reporting
needs from the quality and complaints um
side of things
i also ta for uh currently i'm also
taking for applied linear modeling class
at uh university of pennsylvania for the
social sciences department i'm an avid
hour user um i always have i guess two
or three art projects open at one time
on my laptop um and and i tried to be as
active in
the community for our ladies and our for
the years as much as possible um i
started at boston college in us and uh
my prior education has been in india
uh and i'm also um you know a big promo
proponent of women in data science
analytics and um i've been ambassador of
some of these in the past few years
um and then i'm ready to jump in
um the big motivation for this talk um
was basically came in um for based on
the projects that i was working on
earlier this year
and i had i ended up with a bunch of
projects on exploratory um you know side
of things very open-ended projects where
i just had to figure out something and i
didn't know what where to start
um so as a result of which what happened
was i realized after my third project
that i was doing a lot of repetitive
work and for a person like me i tend
towards automation
and hence you know my idea of um sort of
trying to
streamline or automate as much as
possible of my um you know sort of eda
workflow would be and another i think
the challenging piece of it was that it
was taking so much time for me to you
know get the data generate all these
plots over and over again and i was
ending up with not enough time to
actually look at their outputs and
generate insights out of which
out of it to make better use of my time
um and hence um i i started moving
towards streamlining my thought process
and in in that process um i came across
lots of packages uh some of which you've
already uh you know heard
some of which you may not know um so
let's let's get started um my talk would
be basically divided into two parts one
being the absolute first steps meaning
um these are the packages that you know
will follow in the next subsequent
slides would be about
you would be able to use them or i
preferred using them um when i i come
across a data set absolutely fresh when
i don't know much about it and i'm like
absolutely literally exploring what is
there in that uh you know how many
columns there is you know how how does
how are different unique values looking
in it um and then there will be a second
step of uh the second phase of this
would be when you know we kind of have a
sense of the data but we start to
visualize it a little more specifically
you know i want to look at unique values
and a lot more from you know
some some of the functionalities from
excel also that make things very quicker
for us so
um again coming back to the phase one or
absolutely new um data
exploration phase um
the packages that i discovered and i
want to talk about and share with
everyone uh is the first one being data
explorer package
and what this package does is verbatim
it helps you with three main steps um it
helps you do a lot of explo it
automatically does a lot of exploratory
data analysis for you and the results
that it provides you um allow you to
look into
um you know a faster quicker feature
engineering and then overall it also
provides you this package also provides
you with functions um that you can use
for data reporting purposes uh again
that is about like the the
low level details of what each variable
in the data is and and how
the bivariate and multivariate
relationships um exist in in the data
set that you have at hand um there are
lots of functions that this package
provides but my go-to has been create
report function um and i'll do a little
demo of this um mtx housing is one of
the data sets um available in ggplot2
package which i have
taken to
you know talk about and show the example
for
um the slide is also uh has all the
links to all the packages so
um the
the vignette for this is this is how it
looks like and it gives you all the
details of you know multiple functions
that it provides it also provides um a
way to replace missing values um i'm
probably not gonna go through all the
details of this but this is
one of the very promising um packages
that i've seen and come across um and i
think this is really powerful
um
i can actually demo that first or maybe
i'll just go through the next um package
as well and i'll finish the phase one
and then i'll demo the rest of the
packages
um so moving on the next package that i
want to talk about is data reporter
package um
it was one of the practices that i've i
heard about in a yard conference i guess
more than a year ago now this package
very specifically focuses um or is is
built with the mindset of doing quality
checks on your data it has some of the
repetitive things that you would see
with your data explorer results but
i think the more the stronger part of it
or the better focus of that of this
package is more on the quality of the
data so it tells you
um you know more than just missing
values it also talks about you know what
outliers uh seemingly you would see in
in this column in in this data set
um
and again uh with many other um
functions available my my if i have to
you know just pick one function that is
helpful or that you know sort of brings
out everything uh all the essence of
this package for me is make data report
package uh sorry function and um we'll
go through this demo again for the same
housing data set um and and see
uh you know what are the
additional uh value uh what is the
additional value that it brings um so
again i'll just reiterate that this
package with some similarity to data
explorer but also has its additional
value of how it brings um summary of
data checks and and it helps you
identify the possible errors in the
existing
system that you are in right now
moving on uh i guess kimar package is
pretty um famous i would say probably
more than these two
um
and skimmer package with uh again with
its only one function that could be a
schema skim function
uh that uh
helps you look at the um you know
different values in your column it
provides you so many statistics uh with
very easy to modify defaults um and one
very um i guess a conspicuous difference
between all of these packages is
or or the results of these repo
functions is
that data explorer create report it
gives you um a nice html format response
uh data reporter by default provides you
with a pdf um output and schemar skim
function actually you know throws out
your results in the console so again
that could be another um way of uh you
know reason for choosing whatever you
choose uh
for for the ease of being within the
system like you know within your r
studio window if that's what you would
um want
um so
i guess before we move on i
i don't think i'm sharing everything so
i'm gonna
uh share my
our studio window now
um can you all see my ask [ __ ]
all right so i'm gonna
i guess i will have to sorry i'm gonna
have to share everything because um
i should have
the results okay and
sorry for that um
for me to look around what else i'm
going to show
see if i can just run it here
i could see the report for a second when
you pulled it up the pdf one
yeah this one has okay html one
well in live presentation something
always has to happen so i can't figure
out which pile it was
all right so you should have one
pretty soon all right so
this uh with just one function
i was able to look at this you know um
let me show you this this rich report
that i get
tells me a lot about the data set that i
have and let's say i've not looked at
this dx housing at all and it tells me
how many rows it has how many columns it
has
um you know what type data type it is
you know what the numeric discrete
continuous and how many missing values
do i have
now after that you know quick table it
also tells you
how many missing values you have by
percentage in each of these uh you know
data sets so how many
um in how many columns how many
observations meaning rows
um
then a quick structure of how your data
looks like
now by each column how many of these are
uh you know what percentage of um
rows in in each column are missing and
it gives you a quick bar chart of that
and um you know percentages on top of
that
again everything uh in you know you
would want to do in univariate
distribution bivariate analysis it also
goes up to the extent of
giving you um qq plot to basically test
for um normality correlation analysis i
think a lot of times we also we we do
need these numbers i guess i personally
have not used pca from from these
results but it goes up to that extent so
it's pretty detailed and
um pretty time saving i would say at
least um one day's work for me
uh one day's worth of work when i would
have to i would be probably making all
of these charts and exploring
um you know every individual column um
within within the data set um so that's
um
that's only data explorer um going back
to
uh the data reporter package now this is
how the
output of you know the pdf format of
this output looks like um again like i
said it has some you know repetitions uh
and and for uh
reasonable uh reasons
reasonable reasons um so it gives you
how many rows and columns you have how
many um
now i guess this is the check that i was
talking about so it talks about how many
missing values you have you know how
many prefixed and suffixes white spaces
um so basically that gives you a quicker
sense of you know what data frame or
what the
what column you're looking at what data
types this you know variable is
if you know about it you know you you
basically get a better you are able to
quickly decide if there are any changes
that you want to make
again the summary table of um number of
unique values missing values and it
tells you if there are any um problems
you know one or some of these problems
that have been highlighted
um including the outliers and
misclassified uh numeric or integer
variables
um and
you know things like that so that's i
think that's pretty useful and uh
powerful
um it gives you uh in a similar way
a univariate distribution here with a um
what do you say a
histogram
and a little bit
about the uh the variable itself
um i think the one i do want to bring
in attention to is these values which it
identifies as outliers which may not
necessarily be outliers in your data
but
since it specifically highlights those
values it gives you a sense of um
you know
um
i'm thinking of right word so it gives
you a little idea of maybe something
that you want to go back to and and
check so
it just sort of highlights that you know
it's a sign that you you can go back and
look at this go back to this column and
um
check a little more in detail
so that's um good so you know a lot of
these columns have those uh notes
on outliers here
and then um you know rest is basically
sort of your environment information so
again like i said um pretty pretty
useful information here
you go back to the skimmer
skim function
so this pretty much
um
i should do it this way
so this gives you a lot of information
again some of which is repeated about
how many rows and columns how many um
character and numeric variables it also
um allows you groupings in this case it
says you know the group variable is none
here
and i think that's uh one of the
strongest suits of skimmer i find
against these other two
um so now this piece is uh
is the summary statistics that i was
talking about and i think one that i
personally like a lot is is the this
quick
sort of uh the sparklines but it gives
you the histogram distribution right
here in front of you in in the console
um which is also
kind of useful in especially let's say
for example in this case as the listings
in inventory
column you can see that these are skewed
and you know this one is uniformly
distributed which is
a good piece of information to have
um and going back to the grouping piece
uh you could also use you know your data
to be um
you could group it by
um
let's see what can we group here by
maybe
let's see
let me do it by city or i don't know i
want to do it by date because um
i want to keep it small
and i might have to
actually load
the ones first
so you can see how quickly again for
each year
so let's see
so group column is here so for each year
it is going to give you how
you know different your summary
statistic is for all the rest of the
columns uh again including all those um
histograms in the end so it kind of you
know is another way of uh quickly
looking at your data and especially if
there are more numeric variables than
others um
and now i think we're ready to
should i pause for any questions
i do see there are two questions that
came in on slido and one was from sharon
would you want to ask that one live
sharon
oh wait yeah i'm unmuted thank you
it's the zoom hell i'm on mute
i'm just curious if you if you've tried
these summary reports on very large data
sets and if so how that works it looks
really interesting but it you know if
you've got something with like a million
rows is it not reasonable
yeah i wouldn't say it's not reasonable
but yes i would agree that it would take
relatively longer time and i have
personally experienced that with data
reporter
um i think when i tried it was with the
sort of million you know with the data
set up sort of that tune um that you're
asking and data reporter uh because of i
think what goes in the background it is
generally slower than data explorer or
schema package it
honestly might even take like five to
ten minutes um
but with data explorer if that would be
relatively faster like maybe under one
minute or so um that's that's my
experience
thank you
yeah but yeah with data reporter i
remember how excited i was to share
those results with my team um
it was worth it i guess even if you know
i just ran it and maybe you went to get
a coffee
but um yeah
that's um so hi priyanka
i have a question uh
dp here so uh usually we do after the
universe analysis like we do the
bivariate analysis as well which like
even in the try variant like sometimes
we do it yeah yeah so because
i'm actually you know the beginner in
this day
in this this but i use the python and
all those tools i don't know like what
this tool is basically
number one is that about that one if you
can share the information second one is
when i we go
to the deep level like we need to group
certain things and then do some
aggregate functions on top of it like so
like this this the data explorer like
whatever they report you just show up
which you said look like it's gonna you
know save us our day so such kind of
things can be added into this one or
uh like for that one we have to do it
you know our programming or something
like that
um
can you repeat your question i'm not
sure i'm getting 100 of that
okay
so
you you pulled out a report and that
report was pretty much like
what by default like report came up
there but sometimes we have to do the uh
like okay grouping grouping grouping and
uh
yeah that that pretty much uh this
report yeah
so
i'm talking about the next step like
around the bivariate analysis of the try
so
when we we
group the values and then we put some
aggregate functions so such kind of
things like are also supported by this
tool or for that one we need to do some
programming
um so i guess all of this is you know in
a way our programming either within the
package or uh you know you your you
would be writing it um but i guess to
answer your question um
so this
uh you know the result that you're
seeing right now is just from one
function which again you know it's is in
a way coding you uh you would install
the data explorer package and then you
would write you would some somewhere you
know also write another
um i guess a function you know read csv
or some other way of reading your data
and then you would use
the create report function from data
explorer package to run on this data set
now
if you so to specifically look at the
groupings i would say
i think what you what you can do is like
i was mentioning earlier now if you look
at these vignette of data explorer
package it also provides you with the
smaller functions that are giving these
results
um in in this one so you know if you
look at all these graphs right they are
driven by some other function they're
most of all of this is
let me let
let me put it this way okay let me let
me change the question different way so
this is like the pretty basic stuff
which is it has done like okay getting
the columns information like putting the
charts based on the column between data
missing and all that stuff that's the
first stage which you said
so let me put it this way for example if
you uh in our the uh in our i mean
commonly used data data sets which we
have uh the texas let's say and i want
to find out like which which uh you know
the uh
like the honors properties are highly
listed there and i figure out like the
10 10 out of them now i want to like to
create a subset of 10 which is pretty
much on the grouping of that one okay
hey for these
make a group of certain items which will
help me to lead to the decision that why
they are basically
the top 10 uh con you know the owners
who who their their properties are
highly listed there so now what i'm
saying is we need to group them we need
to find out okay what aggregate
functions need to be used so such kind
of things likewise this single statement
does exist there or not there this was
my question
priyanka
i think priyanka was covering that when
she was going into the individual
functions that were
part of this but i know a few other
people were recommending some other
packages that you might want to might
want to check out as well like eric
mentioned the point blank package
if you want to do a lot of customization
um but i know we're in the middle of the
still in the middle of the presentation
here so it might be good to
save this question
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't meet
you but i'm first time no no worries
i could tell you're excited about it
i i thought of like okay my problem like
gotten getting sorted out within a
minute
so i got too excited i'm sorry no no
worries at all we'll definitely have
more time for your questions right and
with exploration it's it's always you
know an iterative process you you do
something and then you find something
interesting or you know not so
encouraging then you try to poke around
you filter your data to see what is
exactly going on in these 10 uh listings
and then you'll sort of try to find more
so yeah you you've got sort of if you
keep keep going into um specifics um i
guess that's how i appreciate that thank
you
sure no problem uh there's one more
question from you um
so you're asking
the
the explorer uh uh this data explorer
like is it available for the python
library as well i think you're working
on this
yeah it's another package it's only our
package okay
i see mio had asked one other question
um adding a follow-up on sharon's
question
do you or anybody on the call have
advice for eda with big data with
hundreds or thousands of predictor
columns
yeah and i guess i um
the question more is on
he or she has had more challenges
loading this data which is this large
um i guess um
i'm not an expert but i've heard vroom
and arrow packages might be helpful with
this
but i guess it's it's not
in the scope of what we are discussing
so
um i hope it's okay if i move on
definitely i can share those links to
those packages too in the chat while you
continue
thank you sure
so um all right so moving on to uh you
know after after doing a lot of
interesting
uh exploration with different kinds of
quality checks and you know individual
level details of what your data looks
like um
now you know now is when your actual
work starts and you want to see
a lot more
you want to get in more depth of the
data that you have
so
um now on that note i figured i i found
useful uh these following packages where
our pivot table
uh is some is a synonymous to a you know
microsoft excel pivot table which i'm
sure
a lot of us have used before we moved on
to you know before we moved on to our
journey
and um
i personally found it very useful
because i was working with a lot of user
level data but it was in you know in
terms of
um their you know daily activity on the
app and which me meant that the data set
that i have it it's
with so for each user i had multiple
records and every time every time i did
some filtering or you know any sort of
transformation or wrangling of my data i
always from from the qa perspective i've
always wanted to see how many users did
i use out you know in this funnel or in
this analysis
chain
so uh you know always wanting i always
was looking at you know looking at the
unique number of uh users so instead of
having to do
um you know select user id distinct and
then you know give me that count of um
the final number you know i sort of had
created this little chain of my tie
reverse um
code
um but again you know having to do copy
paste that again and again i figured
this package was what um solved my
problem um and then again we'll move on
to which cuisine chronicle as well
um so now within this package uh when i
look at it um i sort of you know the i
created these um
little uh notes here on
how
how how do i find this useful so it
allows me to do a lot of quick and dirty
exploration like i was saying so every
time i would filter the data i would
pipe in our pivot table function in in
it and then you know from that point
onwards whatever the state of my data is
at this point whether it's at the
granular level whether it has been
proved or what not um i could always uh
you know just pick and choose things uh
i wanted to look at you know
um what are the unique number of users i
have or
i per use or level how many records am i
looking at at this point in terms of
their activity and things like that
um so from the demo purposes let's go to
um
the workflow here
all right so
i am going to be looking at
all right yeah
so the demo here is about this
so um
again back to the um tx housing data you
can see
that it brings you pretty much the same
setup as a you know excel pivot table
it allow it you know on on the flight
first it gives me
the count of the entire number of rows
which which is the default right but i
can always look at
um count of unique values
by which column in this case i want to
look at how many unique cities do i have
uh in my case i would go back and look
at the user ids
we could look at how many years data are
we looking at in this case so we have 16
years of data in this tx housing which
is great
um
we could uh
go back and say you know just quickly to
the sum
of the sales values
like how much money are we talking about
here um i could spread this by years
i could
break it up by cities and years and you
know all those things so again this is
pretty simple and i have not even
bothered to actually look if there are
any more functions within this package
um because in in this use case that i
have in the situation that i was in uh
you know being able to do this just
quickly and see oh okay this this looks
very small this looks very high um you
know so based on that and you know maybe
this is a specific
um area of issue that i want to focus on
and that's all i needed to know in in
the exploratory process that i was in um
and when i come across these things you
know i will make a quick note of what
i'm observing and then i'll move on to
doing the next type of things
and i think
one thing that i sort of want to bring
in is the reason why i'm talking about
all of these packages or you know
different iterations in using these is
that when when you talk of an
exploratory project you basically don't
always
need everything for your stakeholders or
for your final outputs in your final
presentations when you're working on
them um and hence i i feel that even
though i am you know very very much an
automation person and uh you know pro
code but
i have started to appreciate that not
all the time i need to create all the
code i don't need to always you know
have a ggplot2 code to
be able to have a look at that final
output
and hence um you know these these quick
um
analyses they they helped me a lot uh
move faster in in terms of what i'm
trying to achieve
um
going back to this discussion um i guess
in in terms of sort of wrapping up this
package and this function um i just want
to talk about some benefits and
limitations that i found um so as i just
demoed you can uh see that you know you
can not just accounts but you can sort
of do any sort of aggregation pretty
much everything uh that you would do
with the pivot table within your you
know staying within your r um
ecosystem within your r studio uh
especially if your data set is bigger it
it proves to be much more useful than
actually moving into an excel and doing
those pivot uh values and letting your
excel hang uh that will not be a
situation here um in without pivot table
function uh and i think what i find
really useful is that it's pipeable so
you know you can have your data at any
stage like i was mentioning earlier and
you could still look at
um
different sort of summary statistics
with your data
um
i guess limitation
probably not is you know in this case is
that you you don't get a code generated
out of you know any uh analysis that you
would do here like i was
uh you know i was looking at unique
numbers i was looking at maybe uh in uh
some form of aggregate
um at that point i i am looking at it
and but as a result uh i'm only seeing
seeing the actual outputs or the changes
that are happening it will not
automatically
generate the code in the back end for me
um which is actually fine for the
purpose that it is solving for me and i
think the bigger reason why i have this
no code as a limitation here because
when we talk of squishy i guess then it
will make it more clearer um and then
you know it's very plain and simple it
doesn't have too much of colors which is
again also not a big deal
but
just to sort of um you know bring in
that it's not too fancy
as such
um
so should i pause for any questions
before i move to the next package
we can hold some of them till till the
end as well
but just a reminder that people can use
slido as well if you want to ask any
anonymous questions too
all right so great uh moving on to
exquisite which is um i kind of really
like this package and i think uh i don't
know i think this was the first package
that we first like earlier talked about
um
you know in our previous conversations
about oh can i give a lightning talk it
was years ago
um but yeah so this package really
allows you a very quick exploration in a
visual manner which i think is what
people would be able to appreciate um it
is
basically a package that runs your a lot
of it basically still um you know
generates ggplot2 packages but with
um with the user level of uh interaction
a ui kind of tableau tableau kind of um
platform for
uh people
um it it also allows you to do a lot of
data wrangling on the go and i will show
you how what i'm you know meaning by
that and it also does the code
generation which was the previous uh
limitation i was mentioning
um and let's do a quick demo of that to
see what um i just said like what it
really means when and i said these
things that it allows to do
um and i think one good thing to know
one thing to know is that when you run
this uh exquisite package colon uh
function squeeze r um it actually brings
up um shiny app for you
um
but yeah it's uh it's fun
so i'm gonna go ahead and do
this
so when once that uh you know shiny app
opens up it gives you um
oh i don't have any video friends right
now um
all right one second i have to close
this first
um
[Music]
okay good
so
let's run this again
great so now uh bringing up the dx
housing again um
when when you bring it this up for the
first time it will always ask you to um
you know share
or pick select which data frame you want
to work with you can change the
environment um you can actually also get
the data from google sheets and some
external files
um
but i guess personally i've just mostly
used something from my environment so
we'll go ahead and say import data
and then this this is sort of um a quick
tableau style visual that appears for
you the ui that comes for you uh it
allows you to you know it it basically
brings all the columns from your data
set here it allows you to you know make
different charts and plots uh as you can
see it
gives you all the defaults of or all the
options that you normally get in a gigi
plot because like i said this actually
runs a ggplot2 in in the
background for you
um
so let's see uh let me
just drag in the sales column so what it
will do is it also gives you a little
warning of you know things that you have
missed out so for the missing values um
that have been removed
which every ggplot2 also warns you in
general so now what this does is by
default since it was a numeric variable
it actually plotted a histogram of this
data uh this entire column you could
choose to change things then uh in
certain cases um you may not be able to
uh you know some of the plots will not
be highlighted if that data type is not
supported
uh but otherwise you know it basically
brings up the limited um functionality
of of the plots that it can make for you
um here again now if i wanted to make
this violin chart um by
i want to say here
all right
so it is going to now make um it changed
the plot by default but you know you get
the idea that you basically can play
around with a lot of these things
um
on the fly and on the go so
i
so come a couple of other things that i
want to talk about is
it gives you all the uh you know like
even you know beautification options
that you call the theme and and the
filtering options that you generally
would write uh to get to your final code
uh
i think most of that is sort of also
covered in in these options here so you
can change your x label y label you can
change the caption and title of
your chart so for example
um let me say a scatter plot here
and you would see that appear
right and then in within the plot
options you can
choose to
vary things here then you know all those
things that you um get
that you would you would always use as a
layer in your ggplot2 command or you
know your ggplot2 code you can um change
the transformation this is the start
piece of it um for the x variable for y
variable
and things like that you can flip the
coordinates if you would want
and there's a option to add smooth line
and again there are generally you would
have some more
um some something
could be different when you change your
plot type and things like that
um for the parent's perspective you
could change
things that you know how you want it to
look like
um
again here
you no i think this is what i was saying
so from the wrangling perspective you
can
just by quickly selecting these values
or you know maybe deselecting values
from this um categorical variable you
can do all that filtering of your data
like you can say it is not its.na is
what you want
so all of these things you know make it
so easy and so quick for you um in in
terms of getting the kind of output that
you're looking for
um
and then the magic part of it is
you get all the code on based on what
you did
here which you could just click here to
insert it in the script right away or
you could copy the clipboard and go back
to your code and write it
um so that's why i guess this is one of
my favorite packages which allows you to
um you know play around with things but
yes i guess the challenge with this is
that as your data gets bigger and bigger
i guess with the million rows this
starts to
lose weight or you know it starts to
hang and take much longer
um but in general i guess um when when
working with that big data what i have
um
what i've always been suggested by my
bosses is that you know start with a
smaller subset
and you know then play around with
things if something seems useful then
you know you can take the code from this
and then maybe run it with a bigger data
set um in you know in the next section
or like code chunk
um but still i i still feel that you
know even if your data is too big
there is definitely a lot of value in in
using this um and you know sort of
saving time
another option that this gives you is um
i think something i missed earlier was
let's see
um all right so since i am not able to
look at the data
um it also allows you to
you know look at your data like just to
sort of get a sense of uh is everything
imported correctly or not or something
as just to make sure that what you are
expecting is actually what it is
um and in on that note it also allows
you to you know sort of course your
values so either you can do it here
uh you know maybe if this is an integer
but you want to make it a factor you can
do that
um it also allows you
i think okay maybe this version has
changed but i guess i've seen that
earlier the coursing option to come in
here
um but um
at this point you can actually do those
things here it also gives you a little
quick summary of your data then you say
apply changes and then you know you can
go ahead and you go back to this
background screen
and
have fun with the data
um okay now for respecting everybody's
time i'm gonna just quickly jump in to
the next one and try and talk less
um
just running through the benefits and
limitations like i was i was mentioning
um
it it allows you to uh it sort of saves
you a lot more time in it allows you to
do exploration as well as generates code
for you when you choose to say okay this
is the one you know you tried five
things you didn't like all of them you
said okay this last one is what i like
and this is what i'm going to keep now
after that you after you've chosen to
keep this you know you don't have to
again go back to try and figure out how
you got to that it gives you a code that
you can just quickly as it is take and
move on
um it does not provide you a lot of
options of summaries as the previous
packages that we've talked about
uh and hence i that's why i see that you
know have using all of these in uh you
know conjunction using
the package or the function for what it
is you know more useful for um would
save you um some energy and time
and uh like i was saying so with respect
to the plot options also there are
the ones that you see so it is limited
in in capacity in that sense uh but
again i think that that's pretty still
pretty powerful it gives you a lot to do
um as against um you know
it's half full not not half um
like
i don't know what i'm saying but i guess
i'm looking at the positive side of what
it allows you to do
um and then the final one is the
chronicle package um
it is a package that allows you to do
quick exploration and report generation
um words wise i guess a lot of what i've
already said
um but to to demo it uh
what it does is it provides you with a
lot of um
add underscore functions and uh it
provides you with render report function
and report columns um you know i've
given a summary of this what these what
these two functions basically are
similar to
and then add functions are actually
wrapper to make functions which
um which is how this is how it looks
like so again even with chronicle uh you
know visuals that you're gonna be
looking at if you still have gg plot two
under the hood
um the function that you would write
would be a make underscore for example
bar plot or a line plot and things like
that but what goes under the hood you
know is really about plot function is
being defined with lots of these um
um what do you say
customizations which you can actually
pass on here so it's just a way of
trapping you know creating a bar plot
with with the layer style to
you know these
uh these options that you can mention
within
um your one function call so in a way it
makes it um
shorter or quicker to to get to those um
final outputs that you're looking at
uh which again like i was mentioning
earlier uh it's really a situation uh
depends on use case where um
a plot two code would be better or a
chronicle code uh would you know using a
function from chronicle would would make
you do things faster
um
and then
it reduces the time to generate plots is
what i was trying to mention because
it's still a code but
it um
kind of um
you know brings it all together and it
tells you like you know you don't have
to look for what
was my continuous scale option or you
know what other theme options that i was
trying to look at so you have all those
options within your function call and
you can choose to um you know change or
not change any of those specifics
um
so let's jump on to look at a demo for
that
um okay actually i don't think i have a
demo for that i do i do
so um
so this is uh how
chronical you know functions look like
so for example if i'm creating a report
i could use um
add underscore text function i could add
a table and a rain cloud and a scatter
plot now
and then
you're basically just piping what all
functions you want instead of you know
plus layer adding the layer using a plus
operator in your ggplot
so this is you know
to me it's it's much more stronger and
powerful in that sense that you know now
at this point you can have tables and
charts and everything all
you know in in a singular report
um and then like i was mentioning
earlier the render report function it
allows you to use more than one generate
more than one output formats um
and uh you could give some titles you
could add uh some more uh fancy
customizations you know in a
markdown format and things like that um
and i'm going to try and see if i can
oh get the demo yes so this is how the
output of um the chronicle demo looks
like on this data set so this is on iris
um i guess i didn't get to change a lot
on this so what you're looking at is all
the um
ad underscore functions that we used uh
at first we looked at we added the text
of which is the title
um then we added the table uh of you
know what we are looking at uh
this is just the height of that actual
data set which we wanted to look at and
you know the title this is how it looks
like
so that piece is just you know you add
it by um
you just had to add this much section to
get that nice table in your report then
you are adding a ring cloud plot which i
think is the most important for me oops
um
because uh i have personally struggled a
lot with creating uh rain cloud clouds
so this was like so simple for me and i
guess this is my one
most important if nothing at all i think
this is my go to why i would use this
package
um so you know it gives me that ease of
doing lots of stuff
and then you know we added a scatter
plot and then this report basically just
has that whatever you needed to do with
it
um you can i mentioned the groups you
can mention what your x and y are going
to be
and then so all of these is generated in
you know this is a object that i created
with all of this uh piped together and
then i say give me this as a report
format i want pdf and i want to rmvf um
formats and
this is one of the pdf format outputs
that i'm showing you
so
um
yeah i guess that's pretty much about it
um
and these are some of the resources uh
links that i've used i guess pretty much
some some of these things that i had
opened and showed you in between
um the bonus uh was these two packages
that i also come across since i actually
did this last presentation last month
and um between yesterday
uh i saw that there is another um
package which is pretty strong in in
terms of again you i think this also
uses a shiny app um in the process is a
de-looker package and a descriptor
package um the descriptor was shared by
indirect partners i should give this
credit to him on i came on my linkedin
feed
um
and yeah with that
i think i'm good and that's all i wanted
to share with all of you
that was awesome priyanka thank you so
much
it's crazy how many packages
there are until i keep up to date on all
of them it's almost impossible exactly
thank you um i see there are a few other
questions and
uh i meant reggie to ask the question on
slido could i
pass the mic over to you to have you
asked that
yeah uh thanks thank you priyanka it was
really a wonderful session especially
the exclusive package that i feel i mean
it will be really helpful for me in my
eda exploration so i had just one small
query like uh when you had all this uh
when you do this eda on this various
data sets
uh
is there any particular package of
choice of packages which is more suited
for
a text heavy data exploration like
data sets which is like
having more
columns or values which are
having more characters rather than
numerics
um
for example i use a skimmer a lot but
that's what i have observed it's very
good obviously if there are more
yeah
but when it comes with text or character
heavy data sets i
i mean it's a struggle for me so right
so based on you know these this list of
packages that i've talked about i would
say
potentially data explorer uh would be
good because then it will throw out like
with the create report it will throw out
all the bar charts with you know the
percentage or or the number of records
that you have for each of those
categories within that variable so for
example you know a month column has
january february march so
you know throughout
what you see in you know how much you of
your data that is that you see in each
month or you know for example if there's
a category where is you know
um slim um i guess i don't want to take
this question if it's a gender you know
male female you would know
how how the things are distributed
within that so
i guess that would be one and otherwise
um it could be our pivot table that
could be useful uh in in the way i see
it
yeah i think our pivot table yeah that
one was really fantastic yes
thanks
thanks
thanks
thank you and i see matthew i just asked
would are you able to share the sample
code with us as well in the presentation
a prior version of this and most of the
report samples that i talked about
they're already on my github um but i
will be um uploading this um
this one
uh that you know this the uh the slide
that i've shared today um the one i was
talking through uh also on my github and
then i'll share the link with rachel and
i guess she'll be sharing awesome
perfect so i will i'll share the zoom
recording link on the meetup page and
then i'll put your the link to your
slides and github there as well
perfect perfect
i'm just going to do a quick check here
and i want to see if there are any
questions we missed from earlier i see a
lot of people are saying thank you so
much priyanka that was awesome
um but feel free to unmute yourself if
there's a question that i've missed
um hi prince i'll be back again
so by any chance by any chance if you uh
like come across like uh these similar
packages for python
um i know pretty much sure like there
will be a lot of them but uh
so
i think uh uh probably there isn't a
parallel for data explorer like with the
same name for um python
and um you'd be i think you'll be really
excited to know there is a lux package
that i recently attended like a data
umbrella um session that i attended and
luxe package in the python ecosystem is
amazing it seemed very promising and i
was like oh my god why don't we have it
in our
um
lux it's
you should explore that it's very
it's i guess a step forward from things
that we've talked about today
it adds a lot of um i guess intuition
behind uh you know what you've done and
the data that it sees and then it gives
you options to do next so it's really
important
got it and this gg plot is uh
like also i think uh
because i never used it it i never used
it or is it only our package it's in our
package plot 2 is an r package which you
uh use for
data visualization so
it um it goes to this theory of
grammar
grammar of graphics and it's a layered
approach where you basically
write first gg plot2 function and then
you use a plus operator to add more
specific customizations to
um to that code so um if you
if you remember seeing this piece here
this portion
um of the code it's not too big but i'm
hoping if you can see this um yeah yeah
plus operator so you basically
uh you know start with the ggplot
function then you keep adding what kind
of plot you want and then you know
specific details about how your visual
should look like so theme
allows you to change uh how the text
should look like how the you know the
color in the background and um the the
grid lines and whatnot can be changed
and then scale continuous and fill
manual these again these are
um how your axis would change
you got it yeah because i am actually
not into r so our side is like only
python is available so i was just
thinking like if any of these packages
are available so i will but anyways i
got the terminologies i got the names i
will try to find out the similar uh
packages which can do the job in python
but i'm just saying okay just in case if
you have a you know
you know you get come across by any
means so just just share it with us
thank you but i appreciate that this was
really you know a
good session honestly
thank you
thank you so much and
i'm not sure if anyone
has experience with this as well but
using our packages from
python as well like i know
in r you can use i didn't actually do
that yeah like you can
but i meant like the other way around
yeah
yeah
brian do you do you know if you could do
that because i know you use
like you use it the other way like with
reticulate and
are marked down in python
but from python could you use our
packages
there is a program oops yep i'm sorry
matt
um there is a program it's alluding me
the name is eluding me right now but
actually it uses ggplot for python um
so
if i think of it in the next minute or
two i'll put it up there
there's something i think called the pi
to r
or or something along those lines that
allows you to use
it's um it's almost like the reverse of
reticulate
yeah um but i don't think it's nearly as
good
i'm trying i was trying to google it
real quickly but i'm i wasn't sure what
it was called
yeah i i don't know i've heard about
this quarter platform which is similar
to our studio but i haven't looked too
much into it
it's um
there it is our pi 2 is the first i was
close i had r r 2 and pi just not in the
right order um
but i i would if you want to mix and
match i was checking to reticulate in
markdown um
in fact i such a side thing i'll
actually do a demo for a lightning talk
on
um doing some pretty advanced reticulate
with our markdown and doing web apps
with it for
for that next chat
that'd be great oh nice
and uh yeah i did just put that in the
chat as well that in january um we will
have a series of lightning talks as well
so if there's
something that you maybe want to do a
five minute talk on maybe a new package
or something that you just learned
you can um
fill out that speaker submission form
there
but it's always fun to
to see all the new things that the
people are learning and all these
packages thank you so much priyanka that
was amazing
thank you i really appreciate your time
and and thank you all so much for
joining them i'll do one last check to
see if there are any other
questions that i miss too
plot nine that's it plot9 uses ggplot
for
python
interesting awesome
thank you appreciate that
perfect
that's thank you sorry guys i have to
just step up for another meeting bye bye
bye
thank you all so much have a great rest
of the day
bye
thank you so much everyone for coming in
um i hope everybody gained something or
the other i i learned a lot in the
process so i appreciate this opportunity